>> Dana: MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
DESPERATE FOR ECONOMIC RELIEF
FROM THE PANDEMIC ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL NEXT MONTH AT
LEAST.
CONGRESS IS HEADING OUT OF TOWN
WITH NO CORONAVIRUS STIMULUS
DEAL IN SIGHT.
CHAD PERGRAM IS LIFE ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH AN UPDATE.
>> IT’S REALLY REMARKABLE THAT
THERE’S NO TALKS ON CORONAVIRUS
RIGHT NOW CONSIDERING THE STATE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE STATE OF
THE ECONOMY.
THE THING WE ARE STARTING TO
HEAR ON CAPITOL HILL IS THEY
MIGHT TRY TO PUT SOME SORT OF A
CORONAVIRUS AID PACKAGE INTO A
BIG SPENDING BILL TO AVOID A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IN
SEPTEMBER.
THAT’S WHY EVERYBODY IS LOOKING
AT SEPTEMBER.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IS
SKEPTICAL.
>> THEY SAID WE ALL WORK BETTER
UP AGAINST A DEADLINE.
NO.
THE VIRUS DOESN’T HAVE A
DEADLINE, NOR DOES IT TAKE A
PAUSE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON’T WANT
THIS UNCERTAINTY SO WE CAN’T
WAIT UNTIL SEPTEMBER 30TH.
SOME HAVE SAID PEOPLE WILL DIE.
>> THEY HAVE TO FUND THE
GOVERNMENT BY SEPTEMBER 30TH OR
FACE A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN THAT
COULD BE CATACLYSMIC IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC SO DESPITE
WHAT PELOSI SAYS, SEPTEMBER
COULD IMPOSE A PRESSURE POINT
FOR ACTION.
NOW THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL KEPT THE
SENATE IN SESSION LAST WEEK FOR
JUST AN HOUR OR TWO EACH DAY IN
HOPES OF AN ACCORD BUT
McCONNELL FORMALLY DISMISSED
EVERYONE UNTIL SEPTEMBER 8TH.
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
>> AFTER THE SENATE ADJOURNS
TODAY, WE WILL HAVE OUR REGULAR
PRO FORMA MEETINGS THROUGH THE
END OF THE STATE WORK PERIOD.
WE TAKE BIPARTISAN CONSENT TO
MEET FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
SOONER THAN SCHEDULED.
>> THE REASON THE ECONOMY HAS
PERFORMED REASONABLY WELL THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS IS BECAUSE
CONGRESS APPROVED BIG STIMULUS
BACK IN MARCH AND ALSO IN MAY
COME BUT THAT’S WHY THEY ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE